quand il y a eu des événements qui ont
lieu dans les années précédentes
que ce soit sous la présidence de
françois hollande ou sous la présidence
de nicolas sarkozy
j'appartenais à une famille et je dirais
largement un courant de pensée qui avait
la décence de s'unir autour du président
de la république est au tour du
gouvernement
vous pensez que ces rejetons ces
critiques sont jeunes à l'unité
nationale dont on peut faire des
critiques mais pas ses critiques qui
sont roborative
je dirais et qui sont des critiques
plutôt politicienne est plutôt très à
droite voire même d'extrême droite
puisque je vois qu'une partie de ce qui
est repris par laurent wauquiez par
exemple faisait partie des propositions
soient de monsieur dupont aignan qui
soutenait madame le pen soit de madame
le pen